we're at the UFC fight this weekend in
Miami which by the way broke when Dana
White came out he talked about how the
last time they were in Miami I think
they did 436 at the door this time they
did 11.9 million beating Madison Square
Gardens record of 11.5 million okay and
he says Miami is what La was 10 years
ago and he's selling Miami so we're
definitely going to come back a year
from now that's the video of him talking
but you know anyways we don't need to
play it but one of the things that
happened is while you're there suddenly
the crowd starts losing their mind
feeling you don't hear
everybody taking out their phones and
then all of a sudden eruption there was
nothing because this guy named Donald
Trump walked in 21
000 phones were lifted everybody's got
their cameras on shaking hands people
are trying to spot is that Mel Gibson
that just shook his hand yeah that's
Mike Tyson sitting next to him of course
Dana White and you know he always speaks
very highly even because of how Trump
helped him out at the beginning and you
know mazwedal gives a speech literally
the place is going crazy we're right
back there by the way in that video so
the place is going absolutely Bonkers
right mosvidel then starts fighting
Burns in the middle of the fight
camera goes on him no one was watching a
fight nobody cares anymore everybody so
so the department comes now here's
here's what the the conversation becomes
either a hundred percent of UFC viewers
are Republicans
or this guy has an energy about himself
when he walks and that he's able to
convert and
magnetic energy I even looked at Adam
for a second and Adam was in tears
wait Adam do you know what that Adam was
can you tell the truth you know what
Adam said by the way if you want me to
tell the truth I'll tell the truth tell
the truth Adam says I'm not gonna lie to
you you know how I feel about Trump I
just went from here to here
very weird feeling right it was actually
cool but you know but you know what
you know it was it was great but but
here here's the part as well the one
thing about politics we had uh uh I said
Ari Fleischer is that George Washington
Ari was here and I said why get into the
game of politics like why why get into
this like he says are you kidding me and
he says unlike Sports where there's a
Leader's bulletin and you know if that
guy scored a touchdown or did this or
did that politics there is no Leader's
bulletin is who can sell their argument
and their ideas better wow it's the
greatest competition and he sold it in a
way that I bet a few thousand kids that
watch it 20 year old guys are watching
saying I want to get into politics he
sold the industry so well wow so don't
do it kids don't do it yeah so the point
is none of us have a clue what the hell
we're talking about when it comes down
to who's going to win who's not you know
the reality of what happened with the
Biden won because they just didn't want
Trump right you know all those vote okay
fine no problem well now you got what
you wanted how happy are you now so if
you like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
thank you
foreign